you got this Occupy Wall Street crowd
that you know wants to know wants to
have a communist revolution but
hopefully we can have more of a
free-market a second American Revolution
and understand that all the pain we're
about to endure is because of government
it's not because of capitalism not
because of the free markets and if we're
gonna have a right future in this
country we're it's gonna be based on
going back to those values the economy's
about to implode I'm like dr. doom you
know we're not even near the bottom yet
so we first we got to have to hit rock
bottom you know it's like there's
expression you know maybe some of the
people here know about you know rehab
and alcohol abuse drug abuse but
generally you got to hit rock bottom
before you before you can you know
actually kick the habit so we're not
there yet I mean we're you know we're
not we're not at rock bottom we're gonna
get there though I mean we're gonna have
a real overdose on cheap money and
government spending and so I I think I
think the real economic collapse is
coming and I think once it gets really
really bad we get a collapse in the
dollar collapse in the bond market
massive inflation lots even lot more
unemployment that we have now that might
be a catalyst to actually do the right
thing and actually you know we go back
to a sound monetary policy and shrink
the size of government if we do that you
know we can recover but right now we're
still we're still we're still headed
down and I unfortunately the
government's not gonna do anything to
prevent this because no the government
never tries to prevent a crisis because
why should they do that they might as
well try to postpone it so they can get
reelected and that's what they're gonna
do and eventually when things are so bad
that they figure either way they're not
gonna get reelected then then maybe
they'll do the right thing but it's
still not a sure thing see the economy
does go down I assume
and then when we reacting me take a
socialist approach and they blame it on
capitalism what is the way out they're
already doing that I mean yeah you know
the Socialists are always gonna blame it
on capitalism that's you know that's how
socialism works you infect capitalism
with socialism you screw it up
the economy gets bad and then you blame
it on capitalism and now and now you
have an a means to promote your
socialism but the only way you can wreck
capitalism is to infest it with
socialism and it's it's it's never
capitalism's fault but capitalism always
takes the blame and so that's that's
their that's their agenda and that's why
it's so important that we kind of
educate Americans to understand what is
the cause of our problems that it isn't
the markets it isn't the greedy rich
people who aren't paying enough taxes
the problem is government all the all
the the well-intentioned government
programs have unintended consequences
that backfire how would you solve this
mess if you were in charge today
you can't just solve it I mean first of
all I mean we've we've been very
profligate we've borrowed a lot of money
we've lived beyond our means we've
decimated our manufacturing base there's
a price to be paid so there is no quick
fix it's like you know somebody is 300
pounds and you know they want to get
healthy I mean you know they got a diet
they got exercise so it's not fun you
know so you know we've got a lot of work
to do we're in a gigantic hole but right
now I know we're making the problems
worse so that's not good all right we
got we got to deal with the problems we
got to admit what they are and yeah I
mean if I had the power to fix
everything I would and you know we you
know ultimately you know the free market
works you know pretty well how long does
this recovery after the crash take and
then what does the world look like
during that recovery and what does the
world
we are in a gigantic hole so it you know
we got a lot of work to do to get out of
it but you know we're not gonna dig our
way out of this hole you know with
socialism it's just not gonna happen so
a lot of it depends on how we react to
this crisis and whether the crisis means
that people blame the government and we
have less government we really you know
we not only do we get rid of the debt we
restructure the debt but we dramatically
shrink government we get rid of a lot of
these entitlement programs a lot of
these taxes and you know we free up the
market so we have real entrepreneurship
and people going out there and starting
businesses and producing products and
hiring people or you know we go
completely the other way and the
government takes over the economy
completely and it's a complete disaster
do you think it's the safest place for
our assets right now I think that the
riskiest places to be in US dollars or
the things that people perceive is safe
Treasuries muni bonds corporate bonds so
you want to want you could own gold you
go silver you can have stocks and
foreign countries as long as you pick
the right countries I think the US
dollar is on the verge of a meltdown
Gold's not going up everything else is
going down that's what gold is telling
you gold is just a barometer it's
measuring the value of currencies and
currencies are losing value but more
important they're gonna lose a lot more
value in the future based on how much
we're gonna create I mean that is the
problem we are going to try to keep reef
lady in this bubble
we're gonna keep printing money it's not
going to work it's not gonna revive the
economy it's not gonna create jobs but
they're gonna keep doing it and the only
thing reason they're gonna stop is they
realize that the whole thing is about to
implode you know there's gonna have to
be a crisis and then maybe we'll do the
right thing maybe we won't maybe we'll
just keep printing until the dollar is
confetti right now you still have this
false perception that the dollar is a
safe haven and as long as that's the
case then we're still living on borrowed
time but when the people start fleeing
the dollar that's when it's over the
government won't let the economy
restructure because in the short run the
restructuring is gonna be painful but
they're trying to perpetuate this bubble
economy it doesn't work you know so the
banks are gonna make anybody the banks
are basically insolvent and as soon as
interest rates rise the banks are gonna
fail again well that's the main reason
that the Fed is keeping rates low but
as they know if they let rates go up the
banks are gonna collapse and the federal
government's gonna be insolvent as well
I've talking institutions that manage
hundreds of billions of dollars and most
of them when I ask them how much gold do
you have how much gold stocks
it's basically zero nothing these are
some of the biggest money management
firms in the world and they have no gold
all right that's gonna change eventually
they're gonna have gold they're got to
buy it from me it's gonna be a lot more
expensive